yo what's up red Del call he's firing up
his oil drone making his brisket with
his dad's secret marinade the end I'm
busy come on yes he said the clients
liked their cars so so he's happy he
wants to celebrate together and why
didn't he call me
I put in the work now dude thinks he can
win me over with brisket nah bruh just
talk it out we'll see that it means I
got a call coming through later
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that was almost
thank you
[Applause]
all right
don't be sad your money
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm gonna bathe the champagne tonight
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
mayor Stevenson you've been in office
for a while now what are your plans for
Lakeshore you know now more than ever we
need to back the boys in blue as they
protect us from those who treat
Lakeshore like their own personal
playground
from graffiti to street racing these
illicit activities are tearing our once
great City apart like wet tissue paper
if you want a cleaner safer Lakeshore
support my plans
exactly what we need more cops who hate
Racers on the streets
[Music]
ah
a
yo check out that tuning kit that's the
look I'd be going for No Doubt
Rydell where'd that come from the tuning
kit I ordered it for a customer but they
never picked it up so it's just
Gathering dust is that for grass yeah
cost thanks boss this will make the car
look dope for the race on Saturday
hey you know we got that big money race
coming up we better make sure our ride
is looking the part
yo tell me when you ready to head out
I'm not spending all night here again yo
you both all hand here tonight uh no I
was just saying we going out oh okay
uh you just be careful out there all
right you got more cars coming in early
too will do boss
damn dude only cares about his business
I hear there's some sick race routes
planned tonight let's tear the lake up
[Music]
[Applause]
check this out some chick is live
streaming about the mayor Alec just shot
me a link Alec yeah you know the guy
from that thing
she's on what's up Lakeshore okay so
tonight's live stream will expose the
corruption behind the no-nonsense for
nonsense policy
cute name right but there's nothing cute
about what's happening to the people of
this city look we have inside
information that will finally expose
this Administration and how they are the
real criminals of Lakeshore
but first do you like your mattress oh
[ __ ]
I think I hate much like this
yo what would you say if I told you
there was a way to make some cash
besides racing I'd say I like both
nothing serious yet but my boy Alec
could be looking for a driver hold up
remind me Alec is friend I rolled with
from before
we were in the same foster home
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
episode just dropped and that is why you
should never feed a possum ice cream
somebody's gonna have to clean that up
but anyway for those of you who are just
joining us we're focusing on the recent
Revelations that mayor Stevenson's
sister holds a prominent role on the
board of Waterside construction yeah the
company that has been awarded the
largest renovation contract in Lakeshore
history
you know I think it's safe to say we can
file that under conflict of interest
right guys on today's episode I'll be
looking at how this was allowed to go
through without facing the public yeah
wait why shouldn't you feed a possum ice
cream
[Music]
foreign
damn you see the buy-ins on some of
these races
we can't get that kind of cash playing
it safe there's got
oh yeah
foreign
[Applause]
all right
okay here we go
24.
thank you
[Applause]
we better lose it fast control is
pursuing the suspect don't mess up now
foreign
[Music]